the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones season a Q&A video in today's
video I want to answer some of the
questions you left me but first let me
just give a quick heads-up about the new
giveaway just in case you did not see my
last video if you would like to enter
for a chance to win an official game of
Thrones t-shirt from HBO's website just
click on the link that is provided down
below whoever wins will get to pick
whichever shirt in size they want and as
always you can enter up to five times to
increase your chances of winning good
luck everyone now let's get started
without wasting any more time let's just
jump right into the questions the first
question comes from Dan Garcia and it
says do you think what the spin-off
series coming that they won't fully
answer any of the questions about why
the night king and the army of the Dead
came back or what they want first I just
want to say this and it is my own
personal opinion if they end the show
and we are still completely left in the
dark about the night king and his
motives I would be very angry however I
think the answer to your question is yes
and no but let me explain what I mean by
that when HBO made the official
announcement about their prequel show
they also released a short description
about the new show and I think that
description did reveal some interesting
details about the current story because
I think it relates directly to the night
king in case you forgot exactly what
that description said let's take a look
at it real quick
the statement from HBO said the new show
will take place thousands of years
before the events of Game of Thrones the
series chronicles the world's descent
from the Golden Age of Heroes into its
darkest hour and only one thing is for
sure from the horrifying secrets of
Westeros is history - the true origin of
the way walkers the mysteries of the
east to the Starks of legend it's not
the story we think we know that last
sentence is the key so do not forget
that it's not the story we think we know
right there gives us a good idea what
the show will be about this will take
place during the darkest hour which is
the long night
that's when darkness fell over Westeros
when the White Walkers allegedly came
for the first time we will also learn
more about the starks of legend and if
you've seen any of my other videos then
you know I fully believe the Starks
directly tie-in to the origin of the
White Walkers
the Starks seem like the good guys in
the current story but I guarantee they
have some dirty secrets from their past
and it ties in to the White Walkers
origin so your question is will we get
some of these answers next season at the
end of Game of Thrones I would say yes
we will definitely find out more about
the night King in the White Walkers
however that doesn't mean we will be
told the truth I think everything we are
being shown in Game of Thrones has been
manipulated and that's why I don't fully
trust the children of the forest and
bloodraven think about it like this back
in season six
we saw the children of the forest create
the night king that's what bloodraven
and the children decided to show brand
but look at what the description of the
new show says the series chronicles of
the world's descent from the Golden Age
of Heroes into its darkest hour and only
one thing is for sure from the
horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history - the true origin of the White
Walkers it's not the story we think we
know now why would the new show need to
reveal the true origin of the White
Walkers
when lief already told us why they
created them is that because maybe the
children of the forest and bloodraven
are liars what brain stark was shown and
told in that cave might not have been
the 100% truth that's why it's not the
story we think we know what if brands
vision of the night King being created
was just a projection they were feeding
him and not the actual truth hopefully
this prequel show gets picked up and
turned into a full series that way we
can find out the truth about the
horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history along with the Starks of legend
in the true origin of the White Walkers
the Starks are connected to the White
Walkers in some way and that's obviously
why bran was recruited by the children
in bloodraven I've already made numerous
videos about this so please go check out
those videos if you haven't already
because in those other
videos I was able to flesh out
everything I am brushing over in this
one go watch my video called the
children of forests biggest secret
exposed I know some people disagree with
me on this one but if I were you I would
not fully trust everything they have
told brand so keep this in mind next
season because whatever we learn about
the night King might not be a hundred
percent accurate even though Bloodraven
and the children in his cave are dead
that doesn't mean they aren't
influencing brand any more they can
still live on in the trees and we don't
know how many children may be at the
gods eye where the main hub of weirwood
trees is at they could still be
influencing brands visions from the gods
eye they might be trying to get the
White Walkers and the humans to wipe
each other out so they can have all the
land back for themselves I mean who
knows but I think this is why the
prequels show we'll go into these
details about the Starks of legend and
the true origin of the White Walkers I
think something else did happen that
were not being told and if they're gonna
show us another origin story about the
White Walkers then that means whatever
the children showed brain and that
vision wasn't the full truth they are
still hiding something
like I said we will find out more
information about the night King next
season but I know me personally I will
be taking it with a grain of salt don't
listen to it and let me just end the
question with one of the quotes from the
books because I think this could be
foreshadowing the true intentions of the
children of the forest in brain Starks
very last chapter in the books he is
having a conversation with lief they are
talking about what happened before the
first men came and what happened after
the children were basically slaughtered
pay very close attention to this because
I think it is very telling before the
first men came all this land that you
call Westeros was home to us yet even in
those days we were few the gods gave us
long lives but not great numbers
lest we overrun the world as deer will
overrun a wood where there are no wolves
to hunt them that was in the dawn of
days when our Sun was rising now it
sinks and
this is our long dwindling the Giants
are almost gone as well they who were
our Bane in our brothers the Great Lions
of the western hills have been slain the
unicorns all but gone the mammoths down
to a few hundred the dire wolves will
outlast us all but their time will come
as well in the world that men have made
there is no room for them or us
she seemed sad when she said it and that
made Bryan sad as well it was only later
that he thought men would not be sad men
would be Roth men would hate in swear a
blood oath sing sad songs where men
would fight and kill now what do you
think the children's true intentions are
ever since men have came over and took
their land they have seen basically
everything go extinct including
themselves now why do you think george
RR martin wrote that last part we're a
brand thinks to himself men would hate
and swear a bloody vengeance if this
happened to them the children sing sad
songs where men would fight and kill I
think this is foreshadowing something
big I think the children still have a
plan to get all their land back now I
know it could be wrong about this I
won't deny that but I think they could
be using brand to help get the other
south of the wall bloodraven can't do it
himself because he's too old and he's
stuck in the damn tree but do you know
how easy it is to influence a little kid
who is desperately looking for some sort
of purpose now that he's lost the use of
his legs all I would say is you should
at least take other possibilities into
consideration but let's move on to the
next question before I go too far down
that rabbit hole the next question is
from John Snow and it says what the
recent news of ghosts having a major
role to play next season
what do you expect they have in store
for us when it comes to ghosts I did
want to touch on this subject because
this news did recently come out and I
usually make update videos about things
like this but I didn't have the time to
make a specific video on it yet so I
will just address it here for those of
you that might not know the special
effects supervisor Joe Bauer told The
Huffington Post ghost is coming back
next season before I go any further I do
want to clarify one thing they didn't
necessarily
lycée ghosts will have a major part to
play next season they said ghosts will
show up they said he is very present and
he does do some cool things so it does
sound like they did hear some of the
criticism from the fans because we all
know ghosts should be near John side at
all times I think we will at least see
that next season when John gets back to
Winterfell
I imagine John will greet him after he
reunites with his family then hopefully
we can see ghosts at his side following
him around before all hell breaks loose
that is the bare minimum they could do
but it does say ghost will also do some
very cool things I think we can all take
a good guess at what that means with all
the different battles on the horizon we
should see ghosts involved in some way
running around in the open battlefield
might not be the best idea
because he could get trampled by the
horses alone but we could see something
similar to what he did during the battle
at Castle black I'm assuming Winterfell
will come under attack so what goes
being there at the castle they may have
no choice but to use everything at their
disposal
so if ghost is gonna do some cool things
next season we will probably see him
attack some more whites at the very
least I'm not really sure what other
cool things he could do at this point I
think it's too late for them to
introduce John's abilities from the
books so I don't think we will ever see
John go inside a ghost
unless Bryan Stark would do something
like this for whatever reason
now that could be kind of cool if bran
needed him to do something very specific
I have said in other videos it would be
nice if bran was able to warg into
Nymeria and bring her entire pack to the
north to fight against the army of the
dead george RR martin did say in an
interview you don't introduce a giant
wolf pack unless you plan on using them
in the future
so hopefully that means Nymeria shows up
too I know some people also like to
flirt with the idea of ghosts the
Nymeria having pups of their own which I
am not completely opposed to this is a
show already full of incest so why not
have the dire wolves partake in those
activities as well it's not like any of
us condone this behavior in real life
but in a TV show why not if that means
we can get some more dire wolves then
I'm all for it but let's move on I want
it to answer this next question because
it does relate to the last one
this one is from Lord of wolves and it
says could the night King have a dead
dire wolf and have that fight ghost
absolutely and this is another reason
why ghosts could do something very cool
next season think about it like this the
night king has been beyond the wall for
a very long time and that's where the
stark direwolves came from so there is
no telling how many animals he has
turned into White's over all the years
he has been active almost every time we
see the army of the dead we see
something new
we know they have bears and Giants and
many years ago it is said that they had
giant spiders as big as hounds and of
course now the night King has a damn
dragon so I would say just about
anything is possible
the main reason why I think this is
possible is because we saw summer daya
being the wall in the cave which was
surrounded by the night king's army now
I know lief did blow up the tunnel but
summer died in the main section of the
cave right by bloodraven and we know
that section of the cave wasn't
destroyed because that's where the night
king was standing when Leif detonated
her an grenade after the night King
killed Bloodraven he could have turned
right around and turned summer into
winter this could be revealed next
season when we finally see the night
Kings entire force at work I've always
suspected the night king could have
other tricks up his sleeve so I would
say yes he could absolutely have a
direwolf in his army that could fight
ghosts
the next question is from Arya Stark and
it says do you think we will get more
flashbacks of Ned Stark in season 8 I
wanted to answer this because I often
see different variations of this same
question I even made a video about this
possibility before season 7 aired but
now that we're heading into the final
season with only 6 episodes left this
doesn't seem as likely as it did before
I'm not really sure what they could use
him for at this point other than having
to do was something about Jon Snow the
only reason I could see them doing this
is really only a tinfoil idea that I had
which was basically when Jon Snow finds
out about his parents he will most
likely be in denial about it so perhaps
brain could do one of two things to
prove it to him bran could send Jon
dreams and show him what happened at the
Tower of joy therefore we would see the
younger version of Ned again or I think
bran could touch the tree then grab
Jon's arm and take him inside of the
weirwood
with them now I know I know that sounds
crazy but hey who knows what brain is
capable of doing at this point or maybe
we could even see John reminisce about
the last time he spoke to Ned when Ned
promised to tell him about his mother
the next time they saw each other I
don't know what else we would need to
see Ned for I know some people want to
see the battle at the Trident or the
tourney at Harrenhal but I don't think
it's necessary anymore even though it
would be awesome to see if you have any
good reasons why we could see Ned Stark
next season feel free to leave them down
below anyways I'm gonna end the video
right here I did leave my post up on the
community tab for those of you who still
want to leave me some questions I will
be making another one of these very soon
if you're having trouble trying to
navigate your way around my channel just
look at the screen right now and I'll
show you where you can find everything
and if you click on my channel name then
you should be able to access the
different options on the channel if you
click on the community tab right here
this is where you can leave any and all
questions for the next Q&A video if
you're ever looking for my email address
or Twitter or patreon link just click on
the About section I know some of you
often ask me where that is located so
this should help you can also find all
my videos right here I did notice that
many of the questions were about topics
that I already did make individual
videos about so if you look through all
my videos you might find the answers to
a lot of your questions also don't
forget about the new giveaway that link
is provided down below good luck
everyone and thank you all for watching
today's video I really appreciate that I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for continuing to support my channel
have a great day I will see you again
very soon
[Music]
[Music]
you